[Music]
on this Sunday night assessing the human
toll of an historic Wildfire season
communities in BC's shoe swap and
interior unrecognizable destroyed 66
years old we have nothing you know with
thick smoke now blanketing much of the
province and Beyond how it and a break
in the weather we are finally feeling
like we're moving forward could make all
the difference in the firefight
Fanning the Flames of misinformation in
the Northwest Territories it is a really
dangerous thing to have during a crisis
like this the dire consequences of
banning Canadian news on social media
and defying the order maybe we'll die
maybe we won't I don't know this is just
the thing that we need to do a couple in
the northern community of Enterprise
stays behind while their town is leveled
by fire
global national with Farah Nasser
reporting tonight Colleen Christie good
evening thanks for joining us
uncertainty and anxiety hang in the air
for a number of communities in BC as the
worst Fire season on record there
threatens tens of thousands in the
province's interior we begin in the
Kelowna area where the large McDougall
Creek Fire is being kept at Bay
[Music]
hundreds of firefighters are pushing
Back Against The Blaze which is now 110
square kilometers in size despite some
growth officials say crews are making
progress there were also no new
evacuations overnight and no new
structures destroyed but thousands of
evacuees still don't know if they have
homes to come back to and for some their
worst fears are already confirmed
what did you just learn I have nothing
nothing left everything's burnt
gone
yeah
I don't know sad
yes
don't know what I'm gonna do
the Flames are also taking a heavy
emotional toll on firefighters even as
improving conditions help them make
gains ah sorry
it's been a long few days
I just want to congratulate all our
firefighters
um
you know there's people up there working
36 48 hour shifts and
they take an absolute beating they know
their families being evacuated while
they're trying to defend their neighbors
home and they just keep going
Richard zusman joins us now from West
Kelowna Richard some much needed good
news on the firefight today
yeah good news in terms of conditions
good news in terms of help Canada task
force one has arrived from Vancouver
they're going to be surveying the area
to assess that damage and give people
those much needed answers Colleen that
they're looking for
okay now I can see a house it's now
Brent Barrett and Daron Archer's routine
every few hours leave the hotel arrive
here pull out the binoculars and try to
get a clue any clue if their home is
still standing yeah I guess there's
anxiety there we just we're walking
through it heavy smoke is setting in
across the central Okanagan they know
homes have been lost here but how many
still a big unknown but not like it's
very smoky you can't see much so so you
just wait I guess for a proper update an
update did come Sunday no news yet on
how many structures have been lost but
some optimism on the firefight itself
winds have remained calm temperature
steady allowing Crews to make some gains
we are finally feeling like we're moving
forward rather than we're moving
backwards help has also arrived Canada
Task Force One now on the ground to help
assess the damage while nearly 500
firefighters from across the province
and Beyond continue to do the work
needed to save homes crews are
optimistic and in good spirits heading
out today because we've got some really
uh really critical objectives that are
going to be met this today and tomorrow
Ron hartloff says when he evacuated he
just tossed the dogs in the car grabbed
important papers and got out the emotion
of the situation pouring out when
thinking about what fire crews are doing
to help one of the fire trucks from 32
was at the light beside me and I started
to choke up and honk the horn gave my
thumbs up and
like the vacuum
evacuation orders are still in place
more than ten thousand people in this
region on an alert more than ten
thousand on order as well in terms of
the work that's being done by this group
they are going to do the assessment and
potentially as early as tomorrow those
in this region will get some details on
uh at least preliminary numbers in terms
of how many structures have been
destroyed and people may start getting
an indication on whether their home has
been destroyed that big question Colleen
that so many people still have they may
finally get that answer all right
Richard zusman in West Kelowna BC
Richard thank you
about three hours to the North in BC's
shoe swap region two out of control
fires have merged spanning an estimated
41 000 hectares it's a situation that's
changing rapidly Alyssa Carpenter is
there Alyssa how are people coping as
they try to stay safe
we are just on the edge of Sorrento a
community of which most parts of that
Community have now been evacuated we can
tell you that there is a new blockade
this is as far into the town side as
we're able to go yesterday we were able
to go about eight or nine kilometers
further into the town site now a lot of
vehicles arriving at that blockade not
realizing that this part of the
trans-canada between Sorrento and Chase
has been closed and there are no detour
signs warning you as you leave Salmon
Arms so some people arriving here
extremely frustrated to find out that
they're being turned around and adding a
couple of hours to their drive now we
have seen several communities go from no
alert to Orange meaning there is an
alert back to no alert it's been an all
hands on deck situation really since
Thursday many of those fighting these
fires are volunteers we caught up with
some of the displaced now camping in a
Walmart and winners parking lot in
Salmon Arm sharing their evacuation
stories with us they're worried about
their homes and their businesses and
many wonder why they haven't seen a
plane or a helicopter overhead when they
know that there is water bombing going
on in Lona in the Okanagan where fires
are raging there well we haven't seen
anything like you know with us it was a
spot fire from the scotch Creek at Spark
and he left it for so long in Scotch
Creek it got away on him because well I
was just going up the mountain it's not
going to attach anything and now you
know Scotch Creek is you know things
approached in Scotch Creek and stuff
like that so yeah they need to have a
lot of resources like we do understand
with Kelowna because it's way bigger
that's the thing is the bombers I mean
you've got to have that water bomber
stuff
that big what was it called the Martin
Mars bomber you know that four engine
thing like that it's like a football
field worth of water poof oh done go to
the next one right but no we got these
little things just peashootering at the
the fires now of course it's a
frustrating time for a lot of people who
live around here despite that spirits
remain pretty high in that Walmart
parking lot we saw the manager going
from camper to camper offering water
asking if everyone is okay doing what
they can to keep Spirits High until it's
safe to go home again Alyssa Carpenter
thank you
drifting Wildfire smoke is shrouding
much of the province including the
densely populated Lower Mainland the air
quality Health index listing a moderate
risk of five to six but to the east in
the Fraser Valley the risk is very high
with ratings above 10. Global
meteorologist Peter Quinlan is
monitoring the situation Peter how long
could these conditions last and when can
British Columbians expect a reprieve
Colleen we are expecting some major
Improvement for Metro Vancouver's air
quality as we take you into the day on
Monday could be back up to a five on the
air quality Health index which is a
moderate health risk meantime in the
interior it is going to be quite some
time before we see some vast Improvement
those off the chart 10 plus levels are
possible right through the week as these
fires linger and what does that even
mean well it means even the general
population should be avoiding outdoor
strenuous activity we don't even
understand the health impacts to
breathing this kind of thick smoke into
your lungs over an extended period of
time that smoke will flood back in
across the interior on day then spread
to the north with a southerly flow on
Tuesday helping clear the air through
Metro Vancouver but some of the worst
air quality for the Fraser Valley and
South Coast areas is possible on Friday
as we get back into a bit more of an
east to west influence so we will
eventually see a paring back of the
special air quality statements as for
the winds in the fire zone they've been
coming in from the Northwest and
Northeast those are going to change
directions on Monday a stronger
southerly wind out ahead of some
thunderstorms that could bring about a
firing backup of some of those hot spots
those thunderstorms can locally have
some stronger wind gusts but these ones
will actually have some much needed rain
for the Okanagan and shoe swap 10 to 20
millimeters are possible hopefully Crews
can get the upper hand with that because
after that by the end of the week into
the weekend daytime highs could return
to the upper 20s or low 30s marking a
return to some very difficult
firefighting conditions Colleen Peter
Quinlan thank you
some rain provided brief respite in the
Northwest Territories where more than
200 fires are burning but wind is
pushing the Yellowknife fire East
towards the city and possible
thunderstorms could spell more trouble
for the communities of Hay River and
Enterprise right now evacuees are
relying on information to know whether
or not what they've Left Behind is safe
but as Jeff sample explains getting
accurate information is now harder than
it should be
reinforcements are on the way
fire crews in Northern Alberta taking to
the skies to join the Fire fight in the
Northwest Territories while back on the
ground Ollie Williams is supporting that
fight with his keyboard Scott can you
turn the sound settings on he and his
small team of journalists make up cabin
radio a digital news broadcaster based
in Yellowknife until last week
with the fire inching closer they fled
on the 600 kilometer Drive the
journalists kept filing stories with the
latest details on the fires and
evacuation we were still pushing those
those updates out because you can't lose
that source of information at that
moment because that's when it's most
needed over the past week their news
articles have become a Lifeline for
Yellowknife residents like Adam
Archibald who just escaped to Calgary
during last week's evacuation he tried
sharing one of cabin radio's stories on
Facebook but the post was denied most
people go to Facebook for their news
information meta which owns Facebook and
Instagram blocked all news content on
its Canadian platforms after Ottawa
tried to force the tech giant to pay
Publishers Archibald says rumors and
misinformation are filling the void it's
basically a gossip page on Facebook
and people were basically getting news
off of there because you couldn't post
cabin radio news feed or anything he
says Maps were being widely shared
falsely claiming the fire was about to
hit the city other rumors said there had
been widespread looting prompting some
residents to try and return to their
homes it's a stupid and dangerous band
there's no two ways of getting around
that so mete could lift the ban again
right now in the interests of
preservation of life in a statement a
meta spokesperson says users can still
access reputable information including
content from official government
agencies emergency services and
non-governmental organizations yes all
of that information is on Facebook but
it's all in different little corners of
Facebook and you have to know where to
go to find it so the role of someone
like cabin radio is to collate all of
that and put it in one responsible place
where people can go and check Williams
and other evacuees also blame the
federal government for creating this
situation in an emailed written
statement the Canadian Heritage Minister
called meta irresponsible and Reckless
for continuing to block news on their
platform during an emergency putting
Canadians in danger
Colleen
Jeff sample in Fort Simpson Northwest
Territories thanks Jeff
coming up first a Shuffle Now a retreat
the Prime Minister and his cabinet in
Prince Edward Island where wildfires
topped the agenda
and the questionable impact of the
latest military support for Ukraine
[Music]
prime minister Justin Trudeau and his
cabinet are arriving on Prince Edward
Island for a three-day Retreat Mackenzie
gray is in Charlottetown where things
officially get underway tomorrow
Mackenzie our wildfires expected to
overshadow the agenda
yeah it certainly could derail The
Retreat here Colleen we did hear from
the Prime Minister when he arrived here
in Charlottetown here's what he had to
say about the wildfires during our
session tomorrow the minister of
emergency preparedness will be joining
us but virtually he's staying home in
British Columbia to continue leading the
federal response and coordinate closely
with the province on the situation not
just in Kelowna but across central
Okanagan and in places where where
they're further threatened by fires
one person we're expecting to hear from
tomorrow is Bill Blair the National
Defense Minister but we won't hear from
harjit sajan the emergency prepared
Minister has stayed back in British
Columbia to deal with the Wildfire
situation there Mackenzie what else is
on the agenda
yeah there's going to be a lot of talk
about housing and affordability really
this is kind of the second part of the
Trudeau liberals Rebrand he shuffled his
cabinet last month seven cabinet
ministers wrote 30 changes in total and
they're really trying to focus on
housing and the economy they'll be
hearing from experts from CIBC a number
of other professors who are going to be
talking about different ideas that
liberals can implement but don't expect
that they're going to be bringing any
policies in they're going to bring those
ideas back to Ottawa where they're going
to have to continue to fight with Pierre
paulia because the conservative leader
is well ahead in the polls right now
most polls either have them between 6
and 10 points at the head of the
Liberals and the key demographics that
Justin Trudeau has relied on Millennials
women and support out here in Atlantic
Canada have really faded away that's why
they're going to be turning to new ideas
that they might come up with here in
Charlottetown to bring to back to Ottawa
when Parliament starts in late September
all right Mackenzie gray in
Charlottetown thanks Mackenzie
fighter jets to Ukraine I had Wendell
arrive and how strategic they'll be
against Russian forces
Russia's Space Program took a hit today
in the high stakes race to get back to
the Moon officials in Moscow say the
Luna 25 spacecraft collided with the
moon's surface after losing contact and
spinning out of control Russia's space
agency had hoped to become the first to
land on the moon's largely unexplored
South Pole where scientists believe
there is a possibility of water an
Indian spacecraft is expected to touch
down on Wednesday
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
is vowing to take revenge against Russia
for its latest attack on the northern
city of charnagiv where a missile strike
killed seven people including a
six-year-old girl
zielinski called the attack vile a
missile hit the center of the city as
people came together during an orthodox
holiday zielinski says in addition to
the deaths another 144 others were
wounded
today Danish and Dutch governments
committed to providing more air defense
to the Ukrainian military up to 61 F-16
fighter jets are being donated but as
Redmond Shannon reports the Jets are
unlikely to have an impact on the war
anytime soon
President Vladimir zielinski inspecting
what he hopes will make a difference in
the skies above Ukraine Dutch prime
minister Mark Ruta announcing the
long-awaited first donation of F-16
fighter jets for the exact name I cannot
give you but we are working from the
fact that at this moment we still have
42 in stock here it was then this short
hop to Denmark for the announcement of
19 more f-16s zelenski finally getting a
feel for a jet he has long pleaded for
more than 70 people from Ukraine is now
on the ground here in Inland preparing
for for training
Ottawa is helping with training and
Logistics even though Canada doesn't
have f-16s the Jets were designed in the
1970s a similar age to the Soviet Europe
Plains Ukraine currently owns the f-16s
however have been modernized one of the
big benefits that f-16s are going to
give Ukraine is that the other weapons
that have been provided will be able to
be used much more effectively Ukraine
has said the first f-16s won't be in
operation until next year we understand
the number of jets we can use in the
future nearest or or not it depends on
the situation and on the experience of
our Pilots getting those Pilots Airborne
is one thing turning them into Aces is
another this is the the kind of
balancing act that Ukraine has had to do
throughout this conflict zelenski is
hoping more countries will follow and is
already pushing for donations of
Sweden's Gripen fighter jets too Redmond
Shannon Global News London
next not recommended but greatly
appreciated commandeering a fight
we're starting to get a look at what's
left of the town of Enterprise in the
Northwest Territories much of the
community is gone destroyed by fire
while most followed the evacuation order
to leave our Jamie Dahl spoke to a
couple who did not choosing instead to
take matters into their own hands
it looks like the week of a war zone
homes livelihoods melted away in a
Twisted searing Heap a living nightmare
some are only now realizing the full
extent of is this your first time coming
back here
[Applause]
I thought if you'll find something but
the garage my house over there
other shops
yes 22 years
happiness and joy
a bunch of nightmares too
[Music]
you know just a mess
I was just thankful and praying to God
and anybody the Creator
Allah baby Jesus anybody that would
listen please you know help me some more
um
give me the courage there were a couple
of people who did try to save the Hamlet
of Enterprise there was no firefighters
here there's nobody here we're the only
ones here
you're here by yourself
Lynn and her partner Mike Kimball defied
the evacuation order and returned home
they say a crew from high level stop
briefly to help but with the Hamlet
Ablaze the couple went to Great Lengths
fighting back the Flames all on their
own
so we went managed to go get a dozer we
broke into the fire department the fire
hall and we stole a fire truck and the
water truck from there how did you
operate that truck that we borrowed
and it's a truck I'm a trucker I turned
the key we got in got the key found the
key started it and the way we went and
the smoke was so thick and sparks flying
it was um it was a little pretty hectic
I'm just it motivates you to go faster
they saved their home and a few others
on their street yeah this is crazy this
is damn maybe we'll die maybe we won't I
don't know this is just the thing that
we need to do residents say 95 of this
Hamlet is completely gone they're now
wondering where was the help where were
the water bombers when they needed the
most
like it's it's just unbelievable
like we're a forgotten land it's like
the people here did it didn't matter
according to the fire chief in nearby
Hay River The Blaze was moving at speeds
topping 20 kilometers an hour
Enterprise got hit pretty fast and we
weren't able to get out there but we are
assisting now we are sent we have crews
out there right now just making sure
that uh they're protecting any of the
remaining structures unfortunately
there's not very many left to protect
and some here told us they don't have
insurance despite the hardship the
people in this little Community have big
hopes to rise from the ruins
right Jamie dog Global News Enterprise
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm Colleen Christie the
Wildfire hardships are devastating but
in what feels like the worst of times
people are also reaching out to help
each other thanks for watching have a
good night
foreign